Give me two minutes and I'm going to
teach you a storytelling structure that
will help you sell more stuff with
copywriting. All right, so let's say you
are in the weight loss niche and you
need to sell a weight loss product.
Okay, you may tell a story where you are
the main character. Okay, here is the
start of your story. Here's the end.
Good things go up, bad things go down.
All right, so we're starting our story
and say you are the main character of
your weight loss story and you say,
"Back in the day, I used to be in really
good shape. Things were well, all of
that." And then things took a turn for
the worst. Okay, this is when things got
bad. Maybe my parents divorced. I was
having a hard time in school and I began
overeing and I added 20 lbs, 30 lbs, 40
lbs and I was becoming anxious and
school was hard or whatever. Bad things
happen. And then when a bad things
happens, this is where enter. You tried
all kinds of things, okay? And nothing
worked. I tried this and I tried this
and I tried this and then enter your
product. Okay. Then one day I tried this
and things got so much better. I lost
all of that weight and now I'm, you
know, 160 lbs and absolutely shredded
and jacked. And this is the same that
can do for you. So this is your product,
okay? And this is what helps people feel
seen. They draw an emotional connection
with you here because you resonate with
them. And then they draw another
emotional connection here when you say,
"I've tried this. I've tried this. I've
tried this. I've tried this." And they
don't feel like failures anymore because
you relate to them. And then finally,
you tried this one thing and this is why
it worked and you got the results. So
this storytelling structure with this
product insert will help you sell more